we're kicking things off with our 2020
roundup first up it's been a rough
couple of weeks for Joe Biden after a
series of embarrassing gaffes it looks
like he has another major problem
overconfidence take a look I've always
been I've done very well in states like
Pennsylvania and Michigan I think that I
have as good a chance or better than
anyone to be able to win in those states
no Democrat has ever won the presidency
of late without winning Pennsylvania I
think I could do well Biden is banking
on voters holding their noses and voting
for him but it looks like it's ready to
backfire check out what one pollster is
saying about Iowa I did not meet one
Biden voter who was in any way shape or
form excited about voting for Biden they
feel that they have to vote for Joe
Biden as the centrist candidate to keep
somebody from the left who they feel is
unelectable
from getting the nomination Katie what
do you think about that well when you
look at the enthusiasm of President
Trump and the number of people are still
going to his rallies backed by the
economy this is going to be a problem
for Joe Biden and the thing that's
happened in the last couple of weeks is
when he's asked questions about his
policy positions when he's running
against Lizabeth Warren for example he
doesn't really want to talk about them
or he has changed them and when you look
at his momentum going into the early
States he's saying I've done well in
Pennsylvania have done well in these
other places he's never done well
running for president right and if you
look at the donor threshold that he has
he has big donors he doesn't have small
donors like Elizabeth Warren and small
donors translate into grassroots
activism people going door to door
talking to their neighbors trying to
convince them to get involved or at
least to think about maybe voting for a
certain candidate president Trump has
that Elizabeth Warren has that I would
say Bernie Sanders has that Biden
doesn't have that at this point and if
he really thinks that people are just
going to hold their nose and as his wife
said vote for him even if he's not the
best candidate I think that he's on a
losing path for sure Juan do you think
he's taking people for granted not at
all I mean he has every reason to be
confident let me just think about today
his argument is I can beat Trump
right and his ability to be Trump is
shown in the polls but look at what's
going on today Trump is doing badly
stock market in turmoil what they lose
600 close to 600 points today the
deficit is soaring Trump is fighting
with Jerome Powell the Fed chief he says
he's worse than the Chinese I mean you
know Trump is telling American companies
what to do and yet he's calling other
people's socialists him I wonder who the
socialist is here it's a patriot oh I
see I see
and and you get into a situation where
it looks like you know what
Trump's number-one claim was I got the
economy and now that claim your dream is
coming true what I'm saying doesn't
doesn't in fact Joe Biden as he sits
there and says I can win pencil I can
win he's can be saying not I'm
delighting in problems but I can come
with solutions and this guy solution
here's the problem with Joe okay the
more you put you out there the more Joe
gaffes you get so but if you keep him
sequestered in a subzero free freezer
out in the woods then he will not be
prepared for the steamroller that is
Trump so you got to put him out there
but at the same time you don't want to
put him out there
the strategy is too rich like to return
to a sense of calm and that button
you're supposed to say Oh Joe Biden is
gonna make you feel more comfortable
but his shakiness undermines it so
you're like you know when you compare
them to Trump it's like going from a
loud dragster to a shopping cart with
three wheels you know it's safe but it
rattles and it doesn't really work so
I'm thinking what is the absolute latest
that somebody can somebody big could
enter this race because this is like an
episode of The Love Boat without Captain
Stubing or Isaac the bartender it's all
supporting casts there's not even Julie
the cruise director up there on the
stage but it's Mary your girl Mary Mary
it's the only person is the only person
who could do this call me Mary Ann and
one masterfully transition to the second
Donald Trump so I do have to mention
that he just tweeted that he's slapping
additional tariffs on China as the
market closed you know just one when you
make your argument for you
viens candidacy it seems to be all about
President Trump that's why this campaign
yet but you know you need somebody who
is inspiring if you want to unseat an
incumbent president the only two people
who've done that in recent history
Ronald Reagan and Bill Clinton I mean
think about how dynamic those
candidacies were that is not what you're
seeing right now on the stage now I
think these fall debates are going to be
a very big factor for these candidates
and for Joe Biden in particular but in
terms of inspiration and lifting the
nation and a positive message that was
really embodied by those two candidates
I don't think you're seeing it here and
it looks like some Democrat primary
voters are voting for Biden as a default
to prevent the rise of the far left our
next bernie sanders getting called out
on the campaign trail after rolling out
his 16 trillion dollar green New Deal
turns out the socialist is a bit of a
hypocrite though when it comes to
climate watch you seem adamant about
climate change of course
so what ways would you take to practice
what you preach if you were to become
president no I'm not gonna walk to
California all right you know look you
know I understand that you know we we
blew the PAX weekend as an example but
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you that
we're not gonna use fossil fuels I'm not
going to tell you I'm not gonna get on a
plane that would not be true I mean it
seems like people like Bernie have a
higher threshold Martha when it comes to
you know walking the walk absolutely I
mean when I watched that moment it
reminded me of when we did our town hall
with Bernie Sanders and it had just been
announced that he made over a million
dollars on his book and I asked him you
know you say that millionaires and
billionaires should pay more in their
taxes so would you volunteer you noted
to walk the walk to say you know what I
should be paying more because I am now a
millionaire no he was mean first of all
any of the things that you're that
you're talking about but why wouldn't
you so he doesn't like to be pressed on
these these issues that he claims to
feel strongly about and that was another
thing you can tell you're right that
that is his biggest weakness when you
accuse him of hypocrisy he gets very
defensive well first I had Bernie better
call up the Obamas because they just
purchased a twelve million dollar
mansion
on the coast now if you listen to the
dams that coast will not be there in ten
years
so the Obamas know something that the
Dems don't that it's all BS which stands
for Bernie Sanders the thing is the
secret to being a progressive is to be
on top because if you're on top then you
could enforce your beliefs without ever
having to adhere to them and then when
people come after you you can be like de
Blasio and you go well you know what I
got everybody else to obey into
sacrifice which allows me to go to the
gym in Brooklyn with our entourage or
with Bernie to own three homes and fly
private or first class yeah that's like
he can root for a recession because he
can you can wait out a recession with
his money well I remember when Beto's
tax returns or financials came out and
people said well why haven't you donated
more to charity since you come from a
very wealthy family and he essentially
said well I am the gift and people like
Bernie Sanders want to control every
type of industry so that the little guy
has to come and beg them for whatever it
is that they need here's the guy that
said that bread lines in Nicaragua were
a good thing right I mean but he's the
one who's a good getting in those words
right I'm so curious because it seems to
me that when I look at the people who
are backing Donald Trump the big donors
they're on top and they seem to be
taking their money in a way into
darkness Donald Trump is doing great
with the big donor with the Steve Ross
isn't on and the little donors well the
60 percent is doing a little better but
you know what you look at the money that
comes from PACs Greg you let the
so-called dark myself that's a huge lead
in this but to get back to Bernie for a
second all of you I think are not
understanding that Bernie is not playing
small ball he's talking transformational
politics on issues that the Republicans
have nothing to say about that he will
be the nominee as I predicted but I
don't know you see I don't know that the
Democrats feel confident that he won't
be easily portrayed he calls himself a
socialist and and what is Trump want
he's a strong candidate in filled-in
energy-wise than Joe you know what the
way that you change behavior especially
when it comes to pollution and the
environment is to do it on an
level and if someone like Bernie Sanders
can't name one possible thing that he's
willing to cut back on when he's telling
everyone else we're gonna tax the you to
the out the wazoo tax the middle-class
su the oil companies completely take
over the government with the oil
companies for no crime that they've
committed and yet he's not willing to
say one thing he's willing to do
finally Liz Warren almost did this again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
parallel is didn't quite learn her
lesson after being trail luckily for her
someone stepped in and stopped her from
another embarrassment
[Applause]
[Music]
using children as props in the article
and this is said it appeared she might
try to dance you can see here that she
might try to dance any thing I actually
know this is making me kind of like her
a little bit better actually you know
what it is it's not her fault
yeah she's just very cool you know I
find this much more endearing than the
you know like you wanna have a beer with
me here's the issue okay they're
choosing the wrong music choose
inspirational music you can't dance to
right like some good death metal would
be good but I mean like you can't you
everybody wants to thinks they could
dance to this song and they get I think
we got a kick Martha McCallum off this
show she is too nice she's with the
struggles of a candidate on stage and
I'm far too rational way for us I'm
giving advice identifies with someone
who can't dance we haven't seen proof of
that that he is not much of a dancer so
maybe you can have Samantha pee for her
I think she's I think one I don't want
to bully her dancing fine great can you
say something mean about it please let
me say that her arms are longer than
mine and that father Scott she's taking
dance lessons from Bader or or yeah or
worse John Spicer yeah or she's a fake
Indian